ja ich bin gar nicht so sehr der Meinung
dass das deine Ablehnung da ist ich
erlebe sie um mich herum das wahnsinnig
viel Spendenbereitschaft und und
Hilfsbereitschaft da und wir können uns
da wirklich eine beklagen wie uns unsere
Projekte Menschen unterstützen aber ich
glaube da bin ich bei meinem Stahl
wieder wir müssen es soziale
Infrastruktur auf den auf das ganze Land
wir müssen es nicht nur klassenmäßig
sehen es muss flächendeckend sein wir
müssen etwas irgendwo Unterstützungen da
reinstecken sondern wir müssen sehen
dass nur die Strukturen ändern wir
müssen lernen dass Armut wie gesagt
nicht nur das Geld im Geldbeutel ist
sondern alle Lebensbereiche betrifft
Armut Horst am Ende Exklusion mein
Religionsgründer unsere Religionsgründer
Jesus von Nazaret hat hat sich den Armen
zugewandt und meint er nicht nur die
materielle Armut sondern das Armut
ausschließt der Arzt hereingeholt das
heißt nicht ähm eine Bildung teilhaben
zu können ist ist
am polit zwischen eine Meinungsbildung
mitwirken zu können ist Armut und
Altersarmut ein ganz großes Problem das
da auf uns zukommt und wir brauchen
lauter kluge Köpfe und offene Seiten
dass wir uns hier nicht verschließen
dass wir Programme auflegen die die
nicht nur irgendwo Löcher stopfen
sondern wirklich ein System entwickeln
wo jeder spürt dass er notwendig gewollt
und wichtig ist
derzeit bei sich in der Gemeinde ich
habe das eingangs gesagt münchen ist
eine reiche Stadt in Deutschland ich
bemerkbar bei ihnen in der Gemeinde das
ist Menschen gibt
ich bin im Glockenbachviertel mehr ich
bin seit 30 Jahren ich erlebte eine
unglaubliche interifizierung also nur
gut situierte können sich dieses Viertel
leisten können da ihr die Mieten
bezahlen die lokale sind voll alles ist
gut gerade jetzt die anderen müssen ich
ich
auf der anderen Seite merke ich aber die
Bereitschaft der Menschen sich nicht
einfach abzuwenden aber sondern jeder
sagt er ja jetzt bin ich heute in diesem
Boot drin mir tut es jetzt sehr neu
nicht so weh und so weiter dass er geht
dann schauen wir über deinen Boot hinaus
und da haben wir als Gemeinde als als
Kirche ein ganzer großen Einfluss und
für den bin ich eigentlich dankbar ich
habe da noch nie Ablehnung erfahren wenn
mein Menschen direkt anspricht und wenn
man Projekte versucht umzusetzen um zu
helfen und noch etwas was mir jetzt zur
auffällt echte wahre Notes war und ist
niemals unverschämt sondern verschenkt
das heißt wir müssen Sie erst einmal
rausfinden erst entdecken aber aber wenn
man sie gefunden haben kann ich zum
Beispiel meine Mitteln jederzeit sofort
helfen weil ich so viel Unterstützung er
war darum möchte mir doch gar nicht
dafür Pauschalisierungen einlassen immer
kühl und sie wollen helfen nein man muss
sie nur darauf hinweisen wenn Menschen
zu Ihnen kommen und lassen Sie uns über
den Mittelstand sprechen Menschen denen
es eigentlich gut geht aber dann kommt
eben irgendeine große Zahlung das Auto
ist kaputt die Waschmaschine ist kaputt
da finde ich doch aber bei der Kirche
keine Hilfe oder doch wir versuchen zu
helfen und wir haben viele Kontakte und
wir haben einen Grundsatz keiner wird
weggeschickt kein Ergebnis wir finden
immer irgendwie eine Lösung darum hatte
diese Programme die ja unsere Caritas
und die Diakonie aufsetzen
Schuldnerberatung des ähm
Sozialberatung direkt der Zugang
komplikationslos zu Gesundheitsvorsorge
und so weiter das sind jetzt die
Programme dazu unbedingt notwendig sind
und dass da die Kirche und das war alle
Kritik die uns Kirchen trifft aber dass
wir da so aktiv sein das muss einmal
hervorgehoben werden und deshalb vor
allem einfache Leute sein ehrenamtliche
Gesetze der engagieren und das ist meine
Kinder so wahnsinnig stolz ja das merkt
einfach man muss sagen das wird nicht
viel angenommen ne der Kirche
die Verwaltungseinheit sind Kirche
wahnsinnig schönes Geheimnis sind diese
hineingekommen bin meine Eltern haben
darum gebeten und ich bin jeden Tag
dankbar dafür dass ich dabei sein darf
und dass ich sie zweiter anbieten darf
einfach als Heimat als ein Ort der
Geborgenheit der Schutzes ganz wichtig
ich war von Anfang an der der im ersten
Moment gesagt hat er bei uns nur ein
Missbrauch passiert wäre das der Worst
Case bereits gewesen wir haben eine viel
viel mehr gehabt aber einer allein hätte
schon genügt wenn man das jetzt mal
vergleicht ich weiß wie gesagt ich kann
das nicht wenn man es mal bei der
katholischen Kirche sieht man hat mehr
ausgegeben für Image Kampagnen als für
die Entscheidung der Opfer und dann kann
ich sein wenn es passiert dann muss man
darüber reden offen und ehrlich und man
muss konsequent
keine geheimer Hilfe aber das immer
hinter wirklich dabei diese drei
Schritte den wir jetzt einmal ausgegeben
haben nämlich Aufarbeitung Prävention
unsere Form
nicht die Ausnahme also wir müssen ja
schon auch einmal den Finger in die
Wunde legen was Carstens Stahl auch
anspricht es gibt so viele Themen gerade
in der katholischen Kirche die
mehraufarbeitung mehr Transparenz
benötigen Themen die man moderner
gestalten muss die Homo-Ehe das Zölibat
wer braucht so etwas noch
das wird offen diskutiert wie wir vor 40
50 Jahren schon bei der Würzburger
sinone gemacht haben jetzt wieder noch
offene wir sitzen die Leute auf Augen
diskutiert aber 40 50 Jahre später nicht
weiter ist oder da gibt's wie sehen
jetzt wir legen diese sammeln können die
Erde und ich ich denke mal ich finde es
sehr unwahrscheinlich tolle Zeit wenn
die die Geschwindigkeit sie wie in diese
Kirche wir uns entwickeln und wie wir
diese Dinge angehen ich werde oft
gefragt wann bitte das ist mir egal
sondern was mich interessiert ist oder
ja
könnte ich hier könnte
[Gelächter]
es geht nicht darum hey die wenige Kante
wie man Bayern sagt sondern es geht
darum was ich habe ich jetzt für einen
Auftrag nämlich eine Kirche zu schaffen
wo sie Menschen auf Augen begegnen
können und vor allem Christus beginnen
können bei Mitleid immer fragen ja ihr
müsst die Leute in Kirch bringen das
muss ich sie mit Christus sind Berührung
bringen der Rest kommt dann von der von
alleine also ihr merkt ich bin da wie er
in seiner Arbeit voll positiv gestimmt
und ich fürchte gar nichts mehr aber
auch die beiden Arbeiten verwenden denn
Missbrauch das ist auch ihr großes Thema
ich will die sie einmal dazu abholen
finden sie stimmen sie zu tut die Kirche
da genug ist da genug Aufarbeitung genug
Transparenz geht man das Thema mit der
nötigen Ernsthaftigkeit mit dem Willen
auch an also wenn ich das jetzt höre ich
kenne das natürlich jetzt doch nicht
scheint es ja da zu sein aber insgesamt
gesehen finde ich es nicht es ist immer
noch so dass man es halt mit einem
gewissen Tabu versieht ganz besonders
immer total schaut
von uns gegangen auf dieser Papst oder
bestimmte Dinge wusste ja die hat er hat
sich später dafür entschuldigt aber er
hätte dem Moment als in dem Moment wo
das wusste einfach handeln müssen und
das ist einfach so wir wollen noch nicht
vergessen dass die katholische Kirche
mit das reichste Unternehmen auf der
Welt ja und ganz ehrlich ich hätte dann
im offen darüber reden und man bitte
wenn ich sehe das für Anwälte mehr
ausgegeben wird als Finanzierung Opfer
dann fehlt viele und ich persönlich bin
auch der Meinung schafft dieses
verdammte Teleport ab ja habt einfach
mal der Körper verlangt und dann lass da
vielleicht den ein oder anderen
Messdiener in Ruhe und wenn es dann
passiert ist dann will ich keine
Vertuschung will offen darüber reden und
dann musst du ein Mensch aus der Kirche
ausgeschlossen werden
ist nicht die Voraussetzung für die
Missbrauch es war ein Ziel über Tiere
unter den Tätern dabei wie in allen
gesellschaftlichen Gruppen ich hoffe Sie
sind
entweder lassen sondern diese
Lebensweise persönlichen Stücken als
persönlichen Interesse gewählt also da
muss man schon ein bisschen
differenzierter sein war ich zustimme
ist dass ich sage es wird nie genug
getan sein das ist das allererste und
ich habe irgendwann mit der Hoffnung
geeignet oder die Perspektive und habe
gesagt wir werden dann mit diesem
Missbrauchskandal vielleicht zum
gewissen Abschluss kommen wenn uns
vielleicht die
Opfer wirklich in die Augen sehen
vergeben können
ich habe eine andere Art und Weise
worüber wir reden müssen ist
Sexualmoral ist wie welche welche Leute
schicken wir in den Dienst heute haben
wir ganze engmaschiges System jeder
ehrenamtliche muss polizeiliches
Führungszeugnis bringen wir doppeltes
Führungszeugnis und so weiter also wir
tun alles damit er nichts passiert aber
und wir müssen gar nicht mehr in der
Vergangenheit kramen aber wie kann ich
Menschen überprüfen wie kann ich sehen
dass sie eine gesunde Sexualität haben
und dann kann ich sie ein so eine
außerordentliche Lebensweise wie ist es
lebt reinschicken
und dort wurden natürlich die großen
Fehler gemacht bevor wir es letztes Jahr
mit meiner Arbeit geschafft haben war
der war der Missbrauch eines Kindes nur
zehn Jahre im Führungszeugnis verankert
wir haben dafür gesorgt und ein paar
Politiker das sind jetzt lebenslang drin
ist kommt nach 10 Jahren oder auch eine
Kirchen haben zehn Jahre gebraucht um
diesen Missbrauches Gewaltdelikte
überhaupt zu definieren aber das nächste
Problem steht er jetzt die Frage der
Verjährung auch ich Abschaffung der
letzten Konferenz München hat unsere
Kardinal auch dort dann gesagt meine
Bremse reingehaut um deine zuvor schnell
irgendwelche
Ergebnisse zu liefern aber das wird eine
ganz schwierige Frage Verjährung Ja oder
Nein gefunden wahrscheinlich können sie
gemeinsam da ganz ganz absolut ich bin
dabei und wenn ich ihm helfen kann ich
helfen
und damit auch das Ende unserer Sendung
bekommen ich danke ganz ganz herzlich
bei gestern bei einer anregende
Diskussion ich danke ganz herzlich ihnen
fürs zuschauen wir sehen uns morgen
wieder bei Villach 8 man sieht gut